i guess for me drifting has always been
so ingrained in
japanese well like japanese culture and
japanese car culture because if it
wasn't for stuff like initial d
or like tokyo drift i would have no idea
about drifting yeah
like meme's a side about tokyo drift
like it is legit the only reason
i knew that japan was famous like as a
kid so
talking to you dying inside yeah talking
to you about like the international
drift scene
i'm gonna be honest like i had no idea
there was an international drift scene i
thought
it was like all japan and everyone was
following that like
it used to be like that it's not right i
mean nowadays
okay so i've sort of come to peace with
initial d and um and fast and furious
and that sort of stuff like it's like
you know i mean look it's like anything
where like you're into something there's
a movie about it people go oh yeah i saw
that movie like
it's not like that but the fact that it
makes it it's it's an
easy it's a wedge to open a conversation
people sort of understand yeah yeah
it's the same thing with with um with
tokyo drift like
the majority of that i mean you can
probably look at the japan side of and
go
now that's not actually what it's like
here yeah but it is in certain ways
but you know they people don't drift in
car parks
like yeah i must say that's just very
irresponsible yeah
yeah yeah no it i mean you you see the
if you're going to see drifting in tokyo
it's going to be like down on the the
docks
in like the big open areas where
i think they had a scene in tokyo drift
at the docks i'm pretty sure they did
they they did they actually did yeah
i couldn't i did my research for this
episode i went over the car park scene
though because like looking because
you go into any car park in like tokyo
whatever like
you can barely drive it's like yeah the
[ __ ] hatsu boxes the
ones can barely get through and then
you're like what the [ __ ]
that's probably the most inaccurate
thing about that but the rest of it like
you know the general theme of what they
talk about is do you like the movie
that's a loaded question yeah i i
honestly i think i would genuinely like
it the movie for its campiness if the
main actor wasn't so [ __ ] awful
[ __ ] can't stand his axe every time
every time he speaks japanese i do
cringe oh yeah right it's so bad
there's a cuts there's a scene that's
been cut out of the movie where they uh
they steal a bunch of tires from a
petrol station and it's got um what's
the guys uh little little
little dog snoop what's what's the
character's name the the actual actor
um nate dog no no no the the the the guy
in the movie
um he's like sidekick he's a sidekick
character i know he's like a he's a
rapper uh
anyway it'll be on screen there's a
scene where like he distracts the
the staff but like speak by you know he
opens a drink and like because he
doesn't have any fears he's like
nani correa like
but it is a good general overview and
there are there are some scenes where
they kind of get into the
the you know the side of where it's kind
of like uh being you know escaping from
reality and free because it honestly it
is like that like you know you go up to
the mountains
at two in the morning and all you can
hear is like
the sound of the crickets and uh that
and maybe a river nearby and
that's it and then all of a sudden you
hear this like screaming coming from the
distance and it's a
you know a bunch of cars and headlights
shining through the trees it is very
cool
yeah right i've seen i've seen footage
of like the late night drifting stuff
and it's like yeah there's a part of me
that's like oh man that'd be so cool to
be in but then at the same time like
so now i i i i i i like my life
you know what i mean exactly basically
what i'm getting out of this is like
initial d
isn't realistic enough compared to tokyo
drift look man i think the the
the again the reality it's the same
thing with the
with the with the wang min like the
freeway racing like the stories that
i've heard
see a lot of those guys don't want to
talk about it too because they don't
they just want to keep it
yeah yeah yeah but when you can get them
talking
like if they've been drinking and stuff
like that like you're just sitting there
going
crap how are you still alive
yeah wow yeah it's really good it's so
cool it's like a lot of stuff like in
japan too where you
you get here and you meet these people i
mean same thing with with you know this
industry
too it's like you meet them and you hear
what they did and stuff they've done
it's like
yeah i always feel like because of how
the culture is and how like strict
everything is i've met like the
craziest [ __ ] people here that might
just do not give a [ __ ] and they're like
all right
this is what i used to do and i feel
like i've never met anyone like this in
the uk
because everyone's kind of like i don't
really care about the rules but yeah
when you get a society that's so strict
normally you get characters yeah
and they're you hear some of the
craziest stories that
you know you don't normally hear about
and you know you really have to
drag it out of them yeah you know what i
mean they'll just mention like this
offhand or off the cuff thing you're
like
something you're like what what please
elaborate